what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so we have three months and well really
less than three months we have like two
months and twenty days twenty something
days in order to get you guys prepared
for infinity war every Tuesday from now
until really to infinity war drops
because I have this scheduled out so the
week infinity war the movie comes out we
cover the entire infinity war story
those of you guys who have been
screaming for part two for the last
three years you're finally gonna get it
in May in this video we are going to
cover the first appearance of Thanos and
the first appearance of Jax a destroyer
and iron man fighting Thanos which is
actually kind of cool now this takes
place in Iron Man issue number 55 and it
was written by jim Starlin now those
people who are very familiar with comic
books know who jim Starlin is for those
people who you know if you're if you're
familiar with that whole thing bear with
me because i imagine there's probably
gonna be a lot of people who are
watching this that don't really know
much about Marvel comics so we talked
about this in our video on Adam warlock
explained but you're welcome to check
out you'll find a link down in the
description but nowadays when you go and
you buy Marvel comics you have stuff
like you know guardians of the galaxy
and you have Ultimates and all different
kinds of stories that will explore the
cosmic Pantheon I mean you've got a
Thanos solo series and Silver Surfer has
been cancelled but you had Silver Surfer
for a little while you had all these
different series out there that explore
the whole cosmic landscape there was a
time when that was not the case when you
had a couple stories here and there but
they weren't unified you didn't read
them feeling like you understood this
graped acute pantheon because it was
largely undeveloped now it wasn't until
jim Starlin popped up boy thomas popped
up and they started doing like these
huge crossover events the crease for a
war and the counter-earth saga and all
that kind of good stuff that dealt with
all these different characters kind of
expanding this cosmology this story
deals with the introduction of Thanos
and Thanos is in a lot of ways the
linchpin of the Marvel cosmic landscape
he's the one guy that keeps coming back
and a lot of the stories that set the
stage for how popular the cosmic
landscape became started with Thanos you
know Infinity Gauntlet and infinity war
and infinity abyss and all those kind of
things it was all predicated on stories
that involved Thanos now initially this
picks off really with Drax the destroyer
just kind of sending out a message to
Iron Man simply telling him to be aware
of the Blood Brothers now this is the
actual introduction of their characters
and for the most part the Blood Brothers
were never really important in Marvel
Comics I mean they were there they were
just henchmen that would pop up from
time to time and
very reminiscent of this era of comic
books because this was published back in
1973 so that's what they also want you
guys to notice the way the characters
talk is kind of dated this is exactly
how comics were published back in 1973
this is kind of cool because for the
most part the Blood Brothers had your
standard gamut of powers - heat vision
and flight I mean they had
super-strength SuperSpeed to a degree
they weren't really like you know
lightning fast they weren't Quicksilver
flash fast but they were still
relatively fast they could easily hold
their own now the funny thing about this
and what did he keep in mind is that
because of the fact that a lot of these
early stories we're kind of crossing
into the era of being grounded which is
to say the night Gwen Stacy died set the
stage for more tangible realistic
characters you don't really see a lot of
flights of fancy when it comes to this
kind of thing you don't really see
things going off the rails in the blink
of an eye it's not really 1960s comics
anymore and so the result is that the
fights largely hand-to-hand I mean for
the most part I a man is able to hold
his own but it's things like throwing
desks using chairs so on and so forth
it's like a like the old hardcore
matches from the WEF back in the day but
it is kind of cool because of course
once Iron Man's taken out he's basically
subdued and brought aboard a ship that
belongs to Thanos now the way the Thanos
is depicted here is something that I
want you to bear in mind because this
was his original appearance his first
appearance and the whole idea was that
he had to be grounded he had to be
somewhat relatable and it would have
seemed too extreme and too far out to
create a character as we see him now
because when you go and pick up a comic
right now let's say you pick up you know
Marvel now 2.0 the Thanos solo series
written by Jeff Lemire the guy's massive
in size and that's how we expect to see
fan oohs and even shortly after this in
fact then next time he would appear he'd
be bid he'd be a lot bigger than you
would expect it really creates kind of
like an imposing figure whenever it
comes to how fan o shows out different
things like that but the other half of
this is also known as Drax the destroyer
now Drax the destroyer over the years
and his publications and Marvel Comics
and we'll see this as we go through this
whole cosmic line of stories he's gone
through different iterations over the
course of his life originally he's like
pretty hardcore right here I mean he
looks like your standard comic book
character I mean the guy's got a pretty
solid physique I mean he's drawn to be
someone who's clearly formidable in
terms of you know what he can do notice
the cape and the boots and the belt very
reminiscent of the old-school Superman
design with regards to his character as
he progressed it was actually a dumbing
down of sorts there was a point where
Drax a destroyer
became stupid and he was just like this
ridiculous character and it worked for a
time but then of course as things
progressed and especially when he got
into like the mid to
thousands when Dan Abnett took over the
whole cosmic landscape wrote stories
like annihilation have you basically had
Drax who came back and he was awesome
like it was it was really cool Drax the
destroyer the way you see him now in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that's Dan
Abnett Drax the destroyer but the whole
idea behind this is we end up getting
this kind of origin of sorts that comes
directly from Drax himself at some point
along the line Drax the destroyer
basically sought out the mind of Tony
Stark and we weren't told originally why
he had done that we were somebody just
told that he did that he reached out to
Tony Stark and basically gave Tony Stark
this huge amount of information on
everything that was going on so it's
almost like a flashback within a
flashback when is I'm happening here is
Tony Stark's warned about the Blood
Brothers ultimately they end up you know
coming after him and basically trying to
find a way to track him down but Drax
the destroyer continues this by
basically saying that when he was
sending all these memories into the mind
of Ironman that he basically gives us
the origin story of Stannis now
Thanos for whatever reason was different
from all the other Eternals on Titan of
course Eternals basically being baseline
humans whose genes were modified by the
Celestials and then took to the stars
but the whole idea is that the Eternals
use a giant computer that simply
referred to as Isaac and as autonomous
in a lot of ways and the Sims that it
runs its own thing it has its own
personality to a degree and it's pretty
cool but it's really more of like a
research system but what we end up
finding out here is that the leader of
Titan is a guy named mentor just this
super smart genius who had two sons the
first was named eros and the second was
named Thanos what is up happening is
that somewhere along the line
essentially Thanos basically turned
against the Eternals and the result was
that after going out and exploring the
spaceways he returned to his home planet
with an army and killed everybody except
for except for starfox and ik mentor the
result is that following the destruction
of all these people on Titan mentor
basically goes to their quote-unquote
deity Chronos now the reason why I say
he's kind of a quote-unquote deity is
because Kronos is not really a cosmic
entity and the traditional sense those
are the guys who are new Marvel has all
manner of like godly beings right I mean
some of them are like earth born like
you have Franklin Richards a son of Reed
Richards who can warp reality on a
universal scale you've got the molecule
man Owen Reese who's one-half of a
cosmic cube basically he's one-half of a
wishing box but then you have the cosmic
entities and the cosmic entities are
designed to represent concepts you know
the cosmic entities aren't really beings
who just somehow rose to godhood on
eternity for example represents all of
time and infinity represents all of
space or I'm sorry eternity represents
space and infinity
represents time some along those lines
Galactus is like necessity yet the
Celestials who were really more like
cosmic explorers with an insane amount
of power but everything serves a purpose
everything represents some facet of
space you know ego and all these
different things like that the result
was that when it came to the character
of Chronos he was originally an eternal
he was a being that lived on Titan he
performs some kind of cosmic experiment
and destroyed his physical form and then
he just kind of took up residence
representing the entire concept of time
itself or something along those lines
and he just became this sort of entity
he's just kind of a cosmic entity that
exists out there but he's really
confined to Titan which is to say the
only time you ever really see him is
when the Eternals of Titan call formed
but the whole idea behind this is that
because Thanos had effectively destroyed
all these different eternals on Titan
itself Chronos at the request of mentor
crafted a being who is perfectly capable
of tracking down Thanos wherever he may
be now there is a reason why Drax the
destroyer was made and there is an
actual basis behind the character which
is to say an origin for Drax the
destroyer himself me we'll go ahead and
throw out there that he's Arthur Douglas
because most people know that by now but
it serves the actual origin we'll go
through that as we progress over the
course of these various you know cosmic
videos but the fact remains here Drax
was created for the purpose of being
able to locate Thanos anywhere in the
universe regardless of where he is now
it doesn't mean that Drax will always
kill Thanos it just means that Drax can
find him as a result the two of them
engage in like a massive conflict of
sorts the moon itself is totally
obliterated in the process and of course
the Drax the destroyer is defeated which
meant that he was brought aboard the
ship of Thanos leading us to the current
moment right now and so of course with
Ironman basically making his way you
know basically overpowering the blood
brothers and then making his way through
the ship ah Drax the destroyer offers
telepathy and says hey look you know
come here come here and then ultimately
he ends up freend rocks bringing them
into conflict with Thanos now again
notice that the structure of Thanos here
he's small it was kind of interesting
because the goal was to make him
relatively intriguing somewhat relatable
not really massive and imposing now
following this and because of the fact
that this was designed to test the
waters which we'll talk about here in a
second dannis ended up becoming a
massive character but with regards to
the whole idea of testing the waters
here one thing to keep in mind is the
way that you see this story play out is
the way that a lot of stories played out
back in the 60s and 70s in Marvel Comics
when they wanted to introduce new
characters now in truth there were a few
ways that Marvel could hand
I mean by and large when Marvel is
introducing new folks or at least at
least joined up bolster as a popularity
of new folks they film into the
Fantastic Four but as new publication
started to come out spider-man and Iron
Man the return of Captain America and
different things like that it became
very clear very very fast which stories
were the most popular ones Iron Man was
hugely popular when he came out and so
what did up happening is that when jim
Starlin got the chance to write a couple
of ironman stories he set the stage and
said well then let's do what we've
always done let's throw that us into
this story let's throw Drax into this
story and then let's see if people care
and that was the idea because of the
fact that you didn't have real-time
reactions you'd have Twitter didn't have
facebook you have reddit or anything
like that publishers like Marvel and DC
had to basically send the character out
there and then wait for the letters
pages to come in which is basically when
fans write letters into the company and
then in turn go through all those
letters analyze those letters alongside
the sales put two and two together and
say okay how do people respond to the
character of fan o's and if it was an
overwhelming amount of support from
people who were just like man I really
really want to see this and if over the
course of three months sales continue to
rise for this one particular comic then
that was an indication people liked the
character of tano's and so he would end
up being brought back but it was cool
because with Thanos kind of showing up
here one of the first things that's
established is that where Ironman and
rocks a destroyer are able to take out
the blood brother stiffed Thanos is no
easy pushover he's able to subdue and
overcome Ironman in the blink of an eye
it's not even difficult it's not even
complicated not only that Thanos
actually threatens to self-destruct the
whole ship and blow them all to
smithereens now of course when you end
up having an energy blast used by Drax
the destroyer combined with the efforts
of Iron Man punching out Thanos
this is when we actually find out he's a
robot and that's when the the whole
attempt to basically bolster interest
and the character comes into play
because what Jim sterling had basically
done here is simply said fan oohs may or
may not return and that was it I mean by
making him a robot they didn't kill the
actual Thanos and so when you were
reading comics back back then you know
back during this point in time things
like life model decoys you know that was
a concept that would that would evolve
over the years but the whole idea was
that making somebody a robot was
basically saying so this guy's not
really thin O's he's pretending to be
Thanos which means there is a Thanos out
there and so how would you guys feel
that version of Thanos came out it was
basically asking the question without
asking it on the nose and that's where
the whole experimentation would come in
how do people respond to it that people
enjoy it do they want to see Thanos make
his return and so again it's pretty cool
because what this does is it ends
pretty rapidly I mean it wraps up pretty
fast these stories have never really
dragged on too long that's the nature of
college from back in the day to kind of
sidetrack for a second there's a huge
difference between the way comics were
published back then and the way comics
are published now for the most part
almost every single story arc was
wrapped up in a single issue if a story
arc wasn't wrapped up in a single issue
in my run for like two possibly even
three issues it was a huge deal if you
had a story that crossed over like six
issues it's like oh my god this is a
massive situation the issue is that as
Marvel and DC began to realize how
popular crossovers were they began to
grow in prominence not only that Marvel
and DC also began to realize big
crossovers were a great way to boost the
readership for alien titles and get
people to check them out if they
wouldn't normally read them and so you'd
have a crossover event that's massive
and everybody wants to check it out and
then you start grabbing alien titles and
then throwing them in there sometimes it
bolstered the popularity of that
character most times fans didn't care
and so the result is that nowadays you
have story arcs that will run six seven
eight sometimes even as high as twelve
issues long like the professional for
example from DC rebirth when it comes to
Deathstroke that was like a seven I
think like a seven or eight issues story
arc back in the 1970s 1980 that was
unheard of there's no way that would
have happened because kids attention
spans were so small we're starting to
see that somewhat return to familiarity
with DC rebirth if you go and pick up a
DC rebirth comic most of the story arcs
you're anywhere between two to four
issues usually they're only about two or
three issues and that's that's really it
sometimes they'll get as high as four
but the shorter issues allow for people
to digest those comics super easily get
the story arcs under their belt grab
what they learn and carry it over to the
next story arc and it really allows
things to feel like they're moving
faster which is a pretty cool technique
Marvel still kind of stuck in the old
days where story arcs were six seven
issues along which maybe they'll move
forward and kind of step into the modern
day I don't know what their weather
business plan is but the fact remains
things kind of been pretty fast it's
basically Drax the destroyer iron man
shaking hands saying hey maybe we'll see
each other again maybe we won't then you
know again jim Starlin choosing the idea
that Drax and you know Thanos may end up
returning later on and then that's it
things are just kind of done so again
it's testing the waters it's
experimenting will people be receptive
to it you know will they like it or not
and so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explained make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and let me know how you guys feel
about these older comics because in
truth the other stories that we're going
to be doing counter-earth different
things like that a lot of those are
going to
written the manner similar to this now
counter-earth is a little bit different
because Roy Thomas wrote some pretty
gritty stories and so there will be
differences but the story of
counter-earth will begin the process of
introducing the Infinity stones and so
that's one of the reasons why I wanted
to cover that as you guys will see the
evolution of the Infinity stones
introduction running all the way up into
the events of Infinity Gauntlet and
afterwards but anyway guys I'm gonna
bring this to an end and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]